l'ordre du jour appelle le vote solennel
sur le projet de loi pour le plein
emploi donc nous avons des explications
de vote de 5 minutes avec un orateur par
groupe le premier orateur sera Monsieur
François Gernigon pour le groupe
horizon il n pas
là
alors
[Rires]
merci Michel il arrive de l'autre côté
il a ouais il
arrive non mais c'est de ma faute j'ai
recommencé une minute trop
tôt monsieur chernigon vous avez la
parole pour le groupe horizon pour une
durée de 5 minutes merci madame la
Présidente
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues depuis
2017 l'ambition claire et résolue de
notre majorité a été la priorité donnée
à la politique de
l'emploi aujourd'hui il est présenté un
projet de loi audacieux qui s'inscrit
dans une vision à long terme pour un
meilleur service public de l'emploi pour
tous un dialogue et un accompagnement
renforcé et une confiance en nos
collectivités territoriales précis
regardons les chiffres notre taux de
chômage n'a jamais été aussi bas depuis
40 ans au 2è trimestre 2023 il est porté
à
7,2% de la population active et 1,7
million d'emplois ont été créés depuis
2017 amenant notre taux d'emploi au plus
haut depuis qu'il est mesuré par
l'INC cette dynamique est le fruit de
nombreuses réformes de nombreux textes
ambitieux
cette tendance à la baisse est
particulièrement notable chez nos jeunes
montrant que notre vision d'un marché du
travail dynamique n'est pas un simple
idéal mais une réalité en construction
avec pour objectif le plein emploi d'ici
2027 le rapport de préfiguration de
France travail nous a présenté un
tableau qui bien que réaliste nous
interpelle il mentionne des
accompagnements peu intensifs de suivi
tardif voir plus for que réel et évoque
des actions peut tourner vers l'emploi
ou
l'entreprise il illustre également à
quel point les parcours peuvent être
éclatés et manquer cruellement de
coordination les entreprises peine à
recruter 18 % des allocataires de RSA ne
sont suivis par aucun
organisme ce sont ces constats qui
poussent à
l'action c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi
audelà des chiffres permettra
transformation profonde avec comme
ambition de renforcer l'accompagnement
vers l'emploi de chacune et chacun tout
particulièrement de ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés du monde
professionnel cet accompagnement se doit
d'être plus efficace plus tangible plus
personnalisé en facilitant leur
parcours avec la création de cette
bannière commune importante qui est
France travail sera rendu automatique
l'inscription de toutes les personnes
sans emploi dont les allocataires du RSA
et les bénéficiaires d'un accompagnement
de Cap emploi et d'émission
local au-delà de cette simplicité
l'enjeu premier est de garantir un suivi
adapté et continu pour chaque individu
de manière
coordonnée le contrat d'engagement
unique vient remplacer la mosaïque
actuelle carifiant ainsi les droits et
devoirs de
chacun sur ce sujet nous avons
collectivement permis d'inclure une
clause pour les 40 Hees d'activité des
bénéficiaires du RSA s'assurant que cela
soit adapté pour les plus énoyés de
l'emploi et les plus
fragiles le texte porte également un
ensemble de mesures pour des
travailleurs en situation de handicap
leur taux de chômage est actuellement au
plus bas depuis 8 ans s'établissement à
12 % en 2022 c'est une avancée notable
particulièrement en comparaison du taux
de chômage global qui est passé de 8 à 7
% entre juin 2021 et juin
2022 mais nous pouvons et nous devons
faire mieux c'est pour cette raison que
ce projet de loi vise également à
renforcer notre
dispositif le titre 3 et ces articles
sont spécifiquement consacrés à
faciliter l'insertion professionnelle
des travailleurs handicapés en outre
avec ce texte en consolidant le rôle des
missions locales au sein du réseau
France travail nous permettons de
reconnaître et amplifier le rôle crucial
elles sont en première ligne pour
accompagner nos jeunes nécessitant un
soutien socioprofessionnel
il est désormais précisé dans le texte
que tous les jeunes suivis par les
missions locales ne sont pas en attente
d'un accompagnement professionnel et
n'ont donc pas tous vocation à être
inscrits à France travail suite à
l'examen en commission enfin je regrette
sincèrement que certains effet de la
petite enfance une arme politique au
détriment des familles des enfants en
supprimant l'article 10 permettant la
création du service public de la petite
enfance et correspondant aux besoins qui
sont remontés après 40 de débat 1490
amendements examinés et 138 amendements
adoptés cette mesure est le reflet de
notre engagement à poursuivre notre
objectif du plein emploi avec ce texte
mais également avec d'autres qui
suivront je pense notamment au travail
en cours avec les partenaires sociaux
sur l'emploi des seneurs qui sera un
autre point capital pour arriver aux
objectifs ambitieux fixés le groupe
Horizon est apparenté soutien évidemment
ce texte je vous en
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Madame Sandrine Rousseau
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
qu'est-ce que faire société qu'est-ce
qu'être une société résiliente telles
sont les questions auquelles ce texte
ses vertus à ne surtout pas répondre des
questions qui pourtant devraient être au
cœur de nos réflexions en ces temps de
monté importante de l'incertitude et de
l'insécurité sur tous les plans dont
évidemment le social et climatique faire
société c'est créer une communauté de
destin sur le fondement de solidarité de
protection commune de capacité à nous
soutenir quand l'un ou l'autre a un
passage à vide telle est la grandeur des
sociétés telle est l'originalité et la
force de la Société française des
institution que nous avons créé et du
système de protection sociale unique qui
fait notre solidité
la recherche de points de PIB ne peut
pas se substituer à un projet de société
l'obsession identitaire non plus la
société est bien plus complexe que cela
bien plus solide aussi que cela et elle
passe par cette capacité à créer les
conditions de notre
solidarité c'est précisément cela qui
est au cœur de ce texte la fin de
l'entraide universelle la fin d'un
revenu de base à la française l'arrêt de
cette promesse fait à chacun et chacune
que nous ne laisserons personne sur le
bord de la route qui est qu'il et elle
auront un socle de dignité de quoi vivre
ou survivre ce que l'on appelle en
jargon administratif un reste à vivre
nous ne tendrons plus la main de la
solidarité sans conditions feu le revenu
de base conçu comme un socle fondamental
et inconditionnel de dignité il faudra
désormais mériter la solidarité ce texte
prépare les conditions pour que de
nombreuses personnes en France vivent
avec 0 € 0 € c'est nous ici dans le
confort d'un hémicycle tapissé de vux
lourd sécurisé par des indemnités
confortables qui allons décider qu'une
personne un humain pourra vivre sans
aucune ressource tel est le vote qui se
présente à nous vous avez adopté sur la
base de théorie économique libérale le
principe étandard des Regan et tachcher
work pay vous avez fait vutre cette idée
qu'il existait une trappe à inactivité
un piège à pauvreté vous n'avez pas
regardé suffisamment attentivement ce
que ce avait produit dans les pays où
ces doctrines ont été appliqué
multiplication par de en Angleterre sous
toucheur de la très grande pauvreté
explosion des demandes aux Banques
Alimentaires accroissement sans
précédent des expulsions de logement ce
ne sont pas des numéros dont il s'agit
mais bien d'humains pour la moitié
d'entre eux de familles monoparentales
évidemment majoritairement parmi elles
des femmes avec enfants dans un quand un
bateau coule on dit les femmes et les
enfants d'abord vous avez mal compris
cette consigne il s'agit de les protéger
en premier pas de les mettre encore plus
en
danger nous pourrions revenir sur tous
les détails de cette loi célérate mais
s'il faut en retenir une chose une seule
c'est qu'elle met le genou sur la nuque
des plus pauvres des plus vulnérables au
nom du fait qu'ils auraient fait qu'ils
auraient une part de responsabilité dans
leur situation bien sûr jamais vous ne
montrer autant de volontarisme et
d'autoritarisme lorsqu'il s'agit de
mettre le genou sur la nuque des pluris
ou des entreprises écocidaires je vais
terminer en faisant un rêve
l'association Global Finance a produit
une étude il suffirait de taxer les
personnes possédant plus de 5 millions
de patrimoine net à hauteur de 2 % 5
millions de de patrimoine net 2 % et ce
possédant plus de 100 millions de
patrimoine net à un taux de 6 % mettre
un prix au carbone pour les entreprises
internationales pour permettre d'offrir
à toutes les personnes les plus pauvres
au au monde un revenu de base et donner
des moyens conséquents aux pays les plus
pauvres i have a dream qu'un jour nous
étudions ici une résolution de ce type
pour donner mandat à notre gouvernement
de faire une transition mondiale qui
soit écologique et juste en attendant
après la baisse des aPL la réforme du
chômage celle sur les retraites et
maintenant cette ce projet de loi nous
nous enfermons dans le cauchemar d'un
productivisme destructeur et aveugle à
la condition des humains comme à celle
de la
planète je vous remercie madame la
députée la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre daréville
pour le groupe Gauche démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers et chers collègues il y
aura une belle enseigne toute neuve un
truc qui clignote un truc qui
flashche BIM
franceurbain dans tout le pays et en
dessous on écrira un slogan le truc que
le président avait dit et qu'on savait
pas trop ce que
c'était on vous explique enfit on essaye
on inscrit un max de monde sur la liste
des demandeurs d'emploi et pourquoi pas
leur conjoint ou conjointe avec on leur
fait signer un contrat d'engagement dans
lequel on leur file une bonne quinzaine
d'heure d'activité obligatoire on sait
pas trop lesquels mais ça leur fera les
pieds on les contrôle on les contraint à
accepter une offre d'emploi FISA sinon
quick on
coupe pour défendre ce projet ces
promoteurs nous ont expliqué que c'était
pour le bien des gens pour les
accompagner nous n'avons pas la même
définition du mot accompagn ce qui nous
est proposé c'est un régime de
coerciition
d'infantilisation de punition le
présupposé est bien connu les privés
d'emploi seraient coupables de leur
situation cette idée va à l'encontre de
toute notre histoire sociale et elle
constitue une négation du réel
367500 offres d'emploi vacante dont il
faudrait discuter la qualité pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles pour 5,4
millions de chômeurs il y a de quoi
traverser la rue plusieurs fois le
chômage est un fléau social c'est une
épreuve il abîme des vies oui nombre de
femmes et d'hommes ont besoin d'un
meilleur accompagnement humain pour se
frayer un chemin mais ce n'est pas le
cœur du plan proposé la Mission de
France travail ne sera pas celle de Pôle
Emploi l'opérateur principal du service
public de l'emploi va devenir une sorte
de garde triage les mission locale dont
le rôle est d'accompagner les jeunes
dans tous les aspects de leur vie vont
devoir rentrer au chospied
dans le dispositif et la confusion
s'organise entre le public et le privé à
but lucratif qui vient s'asseoir à la
table pour nous il n'y a pas de pognon à
se faire sur le dos des chômeurs qui
sont à ce moment-là de leur vie qui plus
est dans une situation de vulnérabilité
particulière le grand marché de
l'activité est ouvert faites vos jeux
alors qu'il y a besoin de formation
qualifiante la pas semble pour l'instant
occuper un strapontin certains nous ont
expliqué vous ne faites pas confiance
aux agents je leur
répondrai beaucoup d'agents ne vous font
pas confiance leurs missions seront
modifiées dans un cadre contraint avec
un pilotage par les chiffres qui peut
rapidement devenir maltraitant c'est
l'institution elle-même qui est ainsi
mise en position d'alimenter la méfiance
des demandeurs et des
demandeuses un groupe de rock
marseillais mythique quartier Nord avait
écrit il y a quelques années cette
chanson elle s'appelle Paul Paul emploi
elle écrit son beau prénom avec un o
c'est trop sympa ce projet n'est pas
trop sympa il a été durci en complicité
avec les républicains et vous auriez
même aimé aller plus loin en catiminé
après nous avoir expliqué les bienfaits
de la suspension remobilisation qui
pourrait faire l'objet
d'une régularisation vous avez essayé
d'y adjoindre un délai de carence
l'obsession de punir tout cela aura
évidemment des effets pour un certain
nombre de personnes et pour leurs
famillees cela va conduire à augmenter
les difficultés sociales à fabriquer de
la dette ce n'est pas ainsi que l'on
peut combattre la pauvreté les
associations de solidarité ont tiré la
sonnett d'alarme ce projet s'inscrit
dans le grand plan de casse sociale mise
en œuvre méthodiquement depuis 6 ans la
réforme des retraites va fabriquer des
chômeurs chez les jeunes et les seniors
les deux réformes de l'assurance chômage
ont réduit les droits des demandeurs
d'emploi la réforme France travail vient
leur mettre la pression pour les faire
rentrer comme des pions dans des casses
ou plutôt bien souvent comme des carrés
dans des rond
ce projet porte atteinte à la solidarité
nationale matérialisée par le RSA ce
projet porte atteinte au droit à
l'assurance chômage àquis est construit
par la cotisation qu'il confond avec un
revenu de solidarité et le tout sera
financé par les cotisations unédique
faite pour assurer un revenu de
remplacement 11 milliards d'euros d'ici
à 2027 les allocations chômage seront
rabauté pour financer le tracking et les
activités le gouvernement a la fcheuse
tendance de croire que ce qui est à
d'autrre est à lui il pioche dans les
caisses sociales par des lettres de
caché comme on le voit à laagirk Arco
dans ce projet il n'est nullement
question de la qualité de l'emploi des
conditions de travail du bien-être au
travail du sens du travail de la
rémunération du travail du travail en
fait il s'agit d'an h le léger regain de
rapport de force pour les salariés
derrière la belle enseigne qui clignote
se cache une nouvelle brique de la casse
sociale les députés communistes et
ultramarins de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine voteront contre cette
mauvaise
loi je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Victor Cateau
pour le rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues après avoir stigmatisé
nos seiors et désenchanté l'avenir de
nos jeunes le gouvernement souhaite
aujourd'hui continuer de martyriser les
Français en s'attaquant cette fois-ci
aux demandeurs d'emploi et aux
allocataires du RSA vous nous demandez
aujourd'hui de voter pour un projet loi
plein emploi qui n'emporte que le nom un
nouveel texte sur l'emploi une nouvelle
chance pour vous de rattraper vos
erreurs du passé une nouvelle chance
pour vous de traiter de la question des
salaires et de la baisse continue du
pouvoir d'achat une nouvelle chance pour
vous de vrer contre la précarité des
jeunes et la difficulté des seiors à
trouver un emploi une nouvelle chance
pour vous de réformer efficacement la
gouvernance des pouvoirs publics en
matière d'emploi loin de saisir votre
chance vous nous décevez une fois de
plus et osez nous proposer un texte au
lacune alors que vous auriez pu réformer
efficacement P emploi pour en faire un
opérateur simple et efficace vous avez
préféré concentrer les débats autour
d'un changement de nom parfaitement
futile et sans intérêt qui ne va
strictement rien changer au quotidien
des demandeurs d'emploi un changeant de
nom a plus de 300 millions d'euros 300
millions d'euros pour changer des
panneaux 300 millions d'euros pour
changer des affiches 300 millions
d'euros pour changer des logos alors que
plus de la moitié des Français sont
aujourd'hui contraints de sauter un
repas sur deux pour continuer de
survivre 300 millions d' EUR pour une
mesure cosmétique alors que vous auriez
pu vous servir de cet argent pour
proposer un parcours d'accompagnement
cohérent au demandeurs d'emploi et aux
allocataires du RSA à la place vous
imposez un contrat d'engagement avec une
obligation totalement lunaire de 15 he
d'activité hebdomadaire mais où
allez-vous trouver monsieur le ministre
chaque semaine près de 30 millions
d'heures d'activité pour l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires du RSA où allez-vous les
trouver vous avez été incapable de
répondre à cette question en commission
incapable en séance et vous êtes encore
incapable d'y répondre aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que vous ne le savez pas
la réalité c'est que vous proposez un
projet de loi plein emploi sans les
emplois qui vont avec d'ailleurs vous
n'avez même pas été non plus capable de
définir ce qui était une activité lors
des débats parce que c'est ça votre
problème à ne rien définir précisément
vous laissz la porte ouverte aux abus la
porte ouverte au travail dissimulé la
porte ouverte à une forme d'esclavage
moderne vous avez parlé de bénévolat
vous avez parlé de service CIVI vous
avez parlé d'immersion en entreprise le
voilà votre projet pour les Français les
plus pauvres les Français les plus
précaires vous voulez en faire de la
madeœuvre bon marché c'est une honte
c'est une honte encore plus grande que
vous ne vous rendez même pas compte du
message que vous renvoyez aux Français
en travaillant 15 heur par semaine avec
votre contrat d'engagement un
allocataire du RSA gagnera 9,35 de
l'heure alors qu'un travailleur os SMIC
n'en gagnera que 9,12 € pour vous il est
donc préférable de signer un contrat
d'engagement et d'être bénéficiaire du
RSA plutôt que de signer un contrat à
temps partiel chaque mois qui passe
monsieur le ministre vous reniez un peu
plus les acquis droits sociaux des
Français chaque mois qui passe vous les
laissez sombrer dans une plus grande
pauvreté et dans ce texte toujours rien
pour les jeunes dont le taux de chômage
est aujourd'hui à plus de 16 %. et dans
ce texte toujours rien pour les seiors
alors que vous demandez au français de
trahir jusqu'à 64 ans vous n'avez
toujours pas pris des mesures destinées
à favoriser la réinsertion et l'emploi
des seigneors sur le marché du travail
votre projet de loi est irréalisable
monsieur le ministre il est déconnecté
de la réalité des Français et nous
sommes évidemment opposés à la vision
que vous avez dans votre majorité vous
voulez réduire les bénéficiires du RSA
en imposant un contrat d'engagement
honteux nous le souhaitons en leur en
réservant ces têtes de solidarité
nationale aux Français vous souhaitez
réformer P emploi en changeant
inutilement son nom nous souhaitons le
faire en réduisant le portefeuille des
conseillers pô emploi afin de garantir à
chacun un accompagnement de grande
qualité vous voulez atteindre le plein
emploi en imposant demandant d'emploi
des heures d'activité nous voulons
l'atteindre en renforçant l'attractivité
des métiers en tenstion et en augmentant
les salaires vous ne souhaitez pas agir
en faveur des jeunes nous souhaitons les
exempter de l'impôt sur le revenu et de
l'impôt sur les sociétés vous ne voulez
pas uvrer en faveur des seniors nous
vrons pour déplafonner le CPF pour les
plus de 50 ans et pour réformer le CDD
seniors monsieur le ministre notre
vision est totalement opposée à la votre
vous uvrez dans l'intérêt de l'argent et
du mondialisme nous vrons dans l'intérêt
de la France et des Français mais ne
vous inquiétez pas monsieur le ministre
nous corrigerons vos erreurs en 2027 je
vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Benoît mournet pour le groupe
Renaissance madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission madames
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues 1,7 million d'emplois créés
200 usines ouvertes près d'un million
d'apprentis un taux d'emploi à près de
70 % 7 % de taux de chômage qui a été
réduit de 19 à 12 pour les personnes en
situation de handicap ces résultats sont
le fruit d'une politique constante
depuis 2017 pour sortir notre pays de la
fatalité du chômage de masse en
s'attaquant à tous les freins identifiés
nous saluons tous nos travailleurs et
chefs d'entreprise de France ainsi que
les le travail de terrain de Pôle emploi
des missions locales de nos
collectivités de tous les acteurs de
l'insertion qui on part dans ses
résultats si le plein emploi est d'ors
et déjà une réalité dans certains
territoires le combat n'est pas terminé
il devient même de plus en plus dur à
mesure que l'on va s'approcher de la
barre des 5 % pour aller chercher les
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
tout particulièrement dans nos quartiers
tout particulièrement dans nos ruralités
dans nos outremire le dernier trimestre
c'est 367000 offres non pourvues 65000
offres d'emplois saisonniers cet été 2
tiers des PME industriels nous disent
renoncer à des opportunités de
croissance faute de P voir recruter et
d'un autre côté certains travailleurs
restent au bord du chemin notamment les
plus précaires ou subissent le temps
partiel peineent parfois faire valoir
leurs compétences ou souhaitent quitter
des entreprises parfois abîmées par des
managements daté alors ce projet de loi
s'inscrit dans une continuité d'action
après les efforts budgétaires sur la
formation professionnelle après la
réforme de l'assurance chômage les
milliers d'accords d'entreprises suite
aux ordonnances travail c'est le fruit
d'un long travail et de dans
l'engagement du Haut Commissaire à
l'emploi que nous saluons une large
concertation 99 propositions tout ça
pour donner du sens donner de la valeur
au travail se fonder sur ce qui marche
et amplifier les démarches engagées
d'aller vert nos missions locales dont
l'accompagnement ça été dit est global
bien au-delà de l'emploi elles
obtiennent des résultats probants sur le
contrat d'engagement jeune nous les
remercions pour cette incroyable travail
de terrain qu'elles effectuent chaque
jour parce qu'elle contribue à redonner
l'essentiel à nos jeunes la confiance en
eux l'objectif c'est de donner du sens
c'est de faire du surmesure pour tous
les publics qui en ont besoin pour les
accompagner durablement dans l'emploi
lorsque monsieur le ministre vous êtes
venu dans les Hautes Pyrénées vous avez
eu ce message fort on n'est pas quitte
de notre devoir de solidarité lorsque
l'on a versé 67 € à quelqu'un nous
sommes quites lorsque on a vraiment tout
fait tout essayé pour le ramener vers le
travail pour ceux qui le peuvent c'est
le sens de ce contrat d'engagement le
RSA que Michel Rocard a inventé est et
demeurera un filet de sécurité
inconditionnel pour les plus fragiles
qui ne peuvent pas ou plus travailler
temporairement ou définitivement c'est
notre devoir de solidarité nationale et
c'est au nom de ce devoir que nous
considérons aussi qu'il est juste et
efficace de réformer le régime de la
suspension remobilisation du RSA bien
sûr une attention toute particulière ça
a été dit et porté au bénéficiaaires
assumant la charge d'enfant d'un ou
plusieurs enfants il est également
nécessaire nous le savons d'approfondir
et d'améliorer la coordination de tous
les acteurs de l'insertion sans plaquer
de schéma national mais en partant des
réalité des besoins du terrain c'est
l'objet de France travail ce projet de
loi renforce enfin l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi en situation de
handicap car si jamais notre pays n'a
compté autant de travailleurs en
situation de handicap il demeure encore
plus difficile pour eux de trouver un
emploi et de s'y maintenir nous
simplifions dans ce texte la
reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés et l'accès aux
droits qui lui sont associés nous
faisons converger les droits des
travailleurs en ESAT avec ceux des
salariés au cours de nos débats le texte
a été beaucoup enrichi notamment sur le
vote du contrôle de la légalité des
offres d'emplois collecté et publié j'ai
été comme bon nombre d'entre vous
interpellé par nos syndicats sur le
terrain sur ce phénomène inacceptable
des offr en doublon ou illégal et nous
remercions les partenaires sociaux pour
cette alerte qui a permis d'adopter
cette mesure à une large majorité nous
serons attentifs à cette mise en œuvre
comme à celle de l'ensemble du texte
afin que il serent d'abord aux plus
fragiles aux personnes les plus
éloignées à nos travailleurs saisonniers
ou intérimaires un seul regret dans ce
texte que l'article 10 sur la
gouvernance de l'accueil du jeune enfant
a été repoussé nous remettrons l'ouvrage
sur le métier car aujourd'hui 150000
personnes essentiellement des femmes
renoncent à un emploi faute d'accueil ce
n'est pas satisfaisant notre groupe
votera donc avec beaucoup de conviction
en faveur de ce projet de loi et je veux
saluer remercier Monsieur le Ministre
les rapporteurs et chacun de vous pour
la qualité des débats qui ont enrichi ce
texte nous souhaitons plein succès à
France travail pour que vive notre
promesse constitutionnelle chacun a le
droit de travailler a le devoir de
travailler et le droit d'obtenir un
emploi je vous remercie je vous remercie
mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas turcois pour le groupe
démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le Haut Commissaire
chers collègues notre société est
confronté à de nombreux mots qui sont
autant de défis que nous essayons de
relever à travers des politiques
publiques sur lequel nous débattons ici
longuement la pauvreté le logement
l'intégration la violence intrafamiliale
le chômage l'éducation le déséquilibre
des finances publiques la santé et la
sécurité et j'en passe sans pouvoir être
réduit à cette seule question l'accès à
l'emploi est un déterminant majeur de
ces problématiques au groupe démocrate
et plus largement dans cette majorité
nous avons la profonde conviction que
l'emploi est un moyen puissant de lutter
contre la pauvreté d'abord et de
travailler en suite tout le cortège des
conséquences qui sont
liées l'emploi est pour nous aussi un
facteur d'intégration et de cohésion
sociale il donne une place à chacun dans
notre société et permet de financer nos
politiques de solidarité qui sont au
cœur de notre modèle
social l'emploi donc était un fil rouge
de l'action des gouvernements depuis
2017 favoriser la formation
professionnelle réindustrialiser la
France lever les verrous administratifs
de l'emploi diffuser largement
l'apprentissage ont été autant de Politi
cohérente autour de l'emploi et les
résultats sont là près de 2 millions
d'emplois créés 900000 contrats
d'apprentissage signé sur un an et un
taux de chômage historiquement bas mais
ne nous en nous nous ne nous en
satisfaisons pas il nous faut aller vers
une société du plein emploi c'est-à-dire
une situation où le taux de chômage sera
inférieur à 5 % c'est l'ambition du
texte qui est soumis à votre
vote il porte une approche ement
différente des politiques menées jusque
là en matière d'emploi en s'appuyant sur
deux constats le premier c'est que les
personnes encore privé d'emploi
aujourd'hui le sont pour la plupart à
cause de déterminants extérieurs aux
questions de formation et de
compéten ces personnes ont souvent soit
ou soit un ou soit des problèmes de
mobilité de santé de garde d'enfant de
maîtrise de la langue ou de
l'informatique et si nous ne considérons
pas ces freins là il est illusoire de
vouloir les ramener vers
l'emploi à quoi bon proposer un poste à
une femme seule avec des enfants si elle
n'a pas de solution accessible
physiquement et financièrement pour
faire garder ses
enfants les acteurs de l'emploi doivent
absolument intégrer cette dimension pour
permettre à ces personnes d'accéder à
l'emploi le deuxième constat concerne
l'organisation des acteurs en charge de
l'emploi et de l'insertion complexe
comme souvent et avec assez peu de
coordination bref un système qui exclut
les plus éloignés de l'emploi et qui
n'est pas source
d'efficacité ce projet de loi propose
donc une approche coordonnée de tous les
acteurs de l'emploi et notamment au
niveau local il faut de la cohérence
dans l'organisation c'est l'ambition du
réseau France
travail et ce texte met en œuvre un
accompagnement 360 derés de la personne
éloignée du travail il faut tenir compte
de tout ce qui freine le retour à
l'emploi cet accompagnement doit être
progressif d'abord et intensif ensuite
c'est une des conditions de la
réussite je déplore cependant que
l'examen de ce texte était l'occasion
pour certains de faire de la politique
sur le dos des plus
fragiles le RSA doit être temporaire et
s'intégré dans un parcours
d'insertion je regrette aussi vivement
le rejet de l'article 10 par la nupè et
l'extrême droite article 10 consacré à
l'accueil de la petite
enfance l'absence de solution de garde
est le frein majeur pour le retour à
l'emploi en particulier pour les femmes
isolées les députés démocrates sont donc
fiers d'agir en faveur de
l'insertion au-delà des mots au-delà de
l'incantation au-delà de la
stigmatisation il faut des actes et nous
les posons à travers ce texte merci donc
pour ce projet de
loi merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur de la
porte pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
socialiste je
juste madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieur le
rapporteur chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous me donner le niveau des
sanctions pour les personnes au RSA leur
montant leur durée leurs effets sur
l'insertion comme je vous l'ai demandé
le 2 mai le 13 le 18 le 20 le 27
septembre le 3 ou le 4 octobre alors
vous ne me répondrez pas plus
aujourd'hui parce que ça fait 6 mois que
nous nous confrontons avec effroid au
vide àissal de vos réponses absentes
face à nos questions pourtant précises
sur votre projet mal nommé plein emploi
face à votre silence face à votre mépris
je suis donc contraint de de répondre à
votre
place monsieur le député je vous
remercie pour votre question légitime
puisque nous nous apprêtons à renforcer
les sanctions et à les systématiser il
s'avère que nous n'avons jamais demandé
les chiffres des sanctions vous les avez
obtenus directement et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'ils sont
inquiétants merci monsieur le ministre
de le reconnaître l'administration nous
confirme donc que la sanction semble
avoir un impact sur le droit au RSA à
moyen terme il entraîne fréquemment la
sortie du droit les chiffres montrent
par exemple que parmi les personnes
sanctionnées en juin 2022 les 2/ers
n'avaient plus le droit au RSA 4 mois
plus tard en tout état de cause ne
pensez-vous pas monsieur le ministre que
ces chiffres démontrent comme le
constate économistes sociologue et la
Défenseur des droits pas plus tard
qu'aujourd'hui que les sanctions
n'engendrent que la pauvreté
accrue merci monsieur le député alors je
suis bien contraint de reconnaître que
sur ce point vous avez raison nous
allons par ce texte créer mécaniquement
de la la précarité en particulier pour
les
femmes merci monsieur le ministre mais
alors pourquoi inscrire automatiquement
ces femmes ou plus largement tous ces
conjoints d'allocataire àemploi mal
renommé France travail je pense
également aux agriculteurs qui
travaillent déjà beaucoup que dire
également de ces allocataires qui pour
40 % d'entre eux travaillent déjà et que
vous jetez à la vindicte populaire en
les faisant passer pour des paresseux
avec vos 15 heures d'activité
obligatoire que vais-je répondre à
Pierre qui m'écrivait il y a pas plus
longtemps qu'hier qu'il estimait que
vous le poussez aller gagner des misères
dans des emplois instables et mal payés
en ajoutant du stress plutôt que de l'an
soulagé ou encore à Magali qui en
faisant une formation financée par pôul
emploi stoppé par l'organisme de
formation reçoit un mail de
désinscription et se retrouve
aujourd'hui sans revenu que vais-je
enfin répondre à Emmanuel myiam iris
toutes ces personnes qui bataillent pour
maintenir la tête hors de l'eau mais que
vous refusez d'entendre aussi et qui
démoigne pourtant des défaillances du
système aussi monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de vous interroger tout
simplement sur le montant des sanctions
que vous allez leur appliquer demain je
vous prie une nouvelle fois monsieur le
député de bien vouloir excuser mon
absence de réponse sur ce point mais
nous refusons depuis le début des débats
d'annoncer le montant des sanctions
probablement pour éviter d'effrayer les
députés qui devraient voter cette loi
afin qu'ils ne puissent pas se rendre
compte que des familles avec enfants se
retrouveront fréquemment avec moins de
300 € par mois après une sanction
pourtant inefficace c'est-à-dire 50 %
des allocations
fonctionner je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre pour cette réponse pragmatique
inquiétante et issue du rapport de la
CAF mais alors dans ce cas-là ça veut
dire que les conseillers du service
public de l'emploi seront débordés par
l'afflux de dossier lié à votre réforme
et devront donc impliquer ces sanctions
pour rendre les pauvres encore plus
pauvres ce n'est pas exact monsieur le
député nous voulons les sortir de la
pauvreté mais comment donc monsieur le
ministre quel moyen allez-vous mettre
pour l'insertion pour l'accompagnement
le rapport de votre notreut commissaire
dit qu'il faudrait à minima plus de 2,3
milliards d'euros et une note que j'ai
par ailleurs publié à la Fondation
jeanures chiffre votre projet de 15 he
d'activité à 10 milliards d'euros il est
vrai monsieur le député que je me suis
contenté d'annoncer 1 milliard d'euros à
horizon 2027 c'est faible mais c'est
déjà ça c'est faible oui mais surtout
comment seront-ils ventilés ces moyens
combien de créations de postes dans les
départements àô emploi quelles seront
les activités proposées comment les
dépenses nouvelles des collectivités
seront-elles compensées
l'honnêteté m'oblige à vous dire que je
suis en incapacité de vous répondre j'ai
tenté d'esquiver le sujet dans les
débats car les 15hures d'activités sont
avant tout un totem pour avoir le
soutien deslr et caracer ce que nous
croyons être l'opinion publique
majoritaire dans le sens du poil c'est
bien dommage monsieur le ministre car
vous êtes en incapacité de mettre les
moyens pour l'accompagnement et vous
reniez la philosophie du RMI qui pait
qui portait symétriquement l'insertion
des moyens l'insertion par des moyens
conséquents et un droit à un revenu
minimum pour suivre tout ceci est bien
loin monsieur le ministre je vois que
vous n'arrivez plus à répondre pourquoi
alors voter ce texte monsieur le député
je dois bien reconnaître que les
éléments objectifs que nous avons
discuté ici devrai m'inciter à conclure
que ce texte n'apportera rien sinon de
la misère et donc à voter contre je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre pour votre
sincérité confondante et vous indique au
nom du groupe socialiste que nous
voterons contre ce terrible
texte je vous remercie monsieur le
député
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Juvin
pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains qui a dit
ça madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues ce débat sur le RSA était
nécessaire il a été l'occasion de
clarifier et de dire les choses sur le
RSA mais aussi sur le travail et sur la
France vous connaissez la situation elle
n'est pas glorieuse 3000 milliards de
dettes la France qui finance toute
nouvelles dépense en
emprintemp la France qui n'a plus de
marge de manœuvre puisque la première
dépense de l'État désormais ce sont les
intérêts de la
dette toutes nos politiques publiques
toutes sont affecté par cette faillite
collective si nous voulons une meilleure
santé une meilleure justice une
meilleure éducation il nous faut de
l'argent et notre argent qu'on devrait
mettre dans nos services publics
aujourd'hui il s'évapore pour payer la
dette aussi je vous le dis avec
gravité toute notre énergie mes chers
collègues sur tous les bands de cette
assemblée devrait être tourné vers une
unique pensée comme rétablir les comptes
publics et se redonner des marges de
manœuvre pourquoi en sommesnous là nous
en sommes là parce que trop d'impôt et
trop de taxes parce que nous dépensons
trop parce que nous dépensons mal et
parce que aussi nous ne travaillons pas
assez alors oui ce débat était
nécessaire parce que ce débat sur le RSA
c'est en fait le débat sur le
travail nous les
républicains nous pensons qu'un partie
de notre système social est dévoyé et
désincite au travail au lieu de ramener
vers le travail avec cette loi sur le
RSA nous voulons une chose très simple
que tous ceux qui peuvent travailler
travaillent quand on reçoit le RSA on a
le devoir de s'engager dans une démarche
d'insertion vers le travail et j'ajoute
que la société a le droit de contrôler
que vous respectez cette obligation
parce que l'argent du RSA n pas gent
magique ce n'est pas l'argent de l'État
c'est l'argent de ceux qui travaillent
et de ceux qui cotisent alors oui je
vous le dis tranquillement les Français
qui travaillent et les Français qui
cotisent ils ont le droit de demander
des comptes sur ce qu'on fait de leur
argent c'est pourquoi nous soutenons la
mesure phare de cette loi que les
républicains ont fait voter quand on
reçoit le RSA on doit faire quelques
heures par semaine d'insertion
j' bien s les parents isolés ou les
personnes malades ou en situation de
handicap mais pas de RSA sans
contreparti le problème de la vie
politique et du débat politique c'est la
caricature certains ont dit qu'exiger
des heures d'activité en contrepartie du
rsa c obliger les gens à travailler
gratuitementinotade madame la
présidenteinotade ces HE c'est
évidemment une obligation pour le
bénéficiaire du RSA mais ces heures
c'est aussi une obligation pour la
société parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous êtes au RSA
une fois sur deux on ne vous propose
rien pour vous réinsérer avec le RSA la
société vous paye pas grand-chose et
vous assigne à domicile et se
désintéresse de vous voilà votre RSA
débrouillez-vous tout seul ça aussi mes
mes chers collègues ça doit changer ce
qu'il faut faut bien comprendre c'est
que ce que vous allez voter c'est
évidemment à la fois une obligation pour
le bénéficiaire du RSA de faire un stage
ou une formation en tout cas plus
d'inactivité mais c'est aussi une
obligation pour la société de former et
de réinsérer dans le monde du travail
ces heures d'activité que vous décriez
tant c'est le pied à l'étrier des
devoirs et des droits alors qui cela va
gêner et bien ça va gêner ceux qui
travaillent au noir mais les autes
autres ils vont se former ils vont se
réinsérer alors je parlais de
clarification nous républicains nous
préférons toujours ceux qui se lèvent
pour aller travailler pour aller en
stage pour aller se former à ceux qui
font le choix
délibéré de ne pas se lever ou aux
assistés professionnels oui je sais ça
vous plaît pas mais voyez-vous c'est
comme ça nous assumons de dire que nous
sommes pour la France qui travaille et
qui se forme mesdames et messieurs tous
les patrons de PME de PME de de TPE tous
les artisans les commerçants les patrons
des pas d'hôpitaux tous les maires vous
diront la même chose il ne trouvent
personne à embauché la réforme du RSA
c'est aussi parce que partout nous avons
besoin d'intelligence et de travailleurs
nous pouvons faire le choix de ne rien
faire mais ne rien faire c'est
abandonner les bénéficiaires du RSA leur
isolement en prétendant les défendre oui
mesdames et messieurs de la LFI je vous
entends mais il n'y a pas de pire ennemi
des Français au RSA que leurs faux amis
voilà mes chers collègues parce que vous
avez compris que le pays se sortira du
gouffre dans lequel il s'enfonce que
s'il travaille vous voterez comme les
républicains pour un RSA qui ramène au
travail et pas pour un RSA qui
anesthésie enferme dans la pauvreté et
contrairement à son but initial exclu
lentement de la
société merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue je vous indique que je fais
annoncer le scrutin dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale il nous reste deux
orateurs la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin saintuille pour le group
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le
rapporteur choisir de parler du plein
emploi en commençant par la réforme du
RSA c'est laisser penser à nos
compatriotes que tout a été fait pour
que chacun soit en situation de vivre
dignement de son travail c'est une
erreur que de le penser à ce stade
puisque depuis le premier jour de cette
législature le groupe PL demande une
conférence sociale sur les salaires pour
que nous puissions parler du travail des
revenus du travail et particulièrement
pour les travailleurs pauvres qui
aujourd'hui encore sont conscients que
malgré leurs fort ils ont une situation
qui reste extrêmement précaire rien non
plus sur la reprise d'activité celle qui
doit garantir à celui qui retourne vers
l'emploi qu'il sera mieux rémunéré qu'un
revenu d'assistance aussi fragile
soit-il vous avez fait le choix de
porter ce texte à un moment d'inflation
extrêmement important alors que les prix
continuent à galoper et que le pouvoir
d'achat est largement
fragilisé tout au long de ce texte nous
avons fait en sorte de faire des
propositions qui correspondent à notre
philosophie celle qui croit au mérite
celles qui croi au travail celles qui
n'affaiblit pas ceux qui sont déjà dans
la fragilité nous vous avons proposé de
revenir sur l'inscription automatique
des conjoints vous l'avez refusé nous
vous avons proposé un contrat
d'engagement réciproque
renforcé sur la base du volontariat vous
l'avez refusé un peu de silence mes
chers collègues nous vous avons proposé
une bonification du RSA pour ceux qui
seraient en situation de tenir les
engagements renforcés parce que nous
croyons au mérite vous l'avez refusé
nous vous avons proposé des sanctions
plus souples plus agiles qui n'enfoncent
pas les gens dans plus de pauvreté vous
l'avez refusé nous vous avons proposé de
travailler et de légiférer pour tous les
territoires de France qu'il soit
hexagonaux ou d'outr m vous l'avez
refusé nous vous avons proposé de
travailler
en attendant le retour d'expérimentation
vous l'avez refusé difficile dans ces
conditions de considérer que le dialogue
a effectivement eu lieu pire entre le
texte qui nous arrive du Sénat et celui
qui est soumis à notre approbation
aujourd'hui il y a eu le mariage coûteux
avec les républicains sous la base d'un
amendement qui a été celui qui scellit
la noce qui prévoit alors même que vous
l'aviez annoncé que les 15h soient
inscrits dans le texte alors même que
vous m'aviez dit à moi et à d'autres que
vous ne le souhaitiez pas alors même
qu'une partie de la majorité avait fait
savoir qu'elle souhaitait la
progressivité sur ses heures d'activité
non casselan tienne vous avez cédé et
considéré que la seule alliance possible
c'était celle avec les républicains cela
se respecte mais mon petit doigt me dit
que cela ne durera pas de manière
générale parce que nous nous sommes en
prise avec le terrain tous les jours
nous savons que ces heures d'activité
elles ont un caractère inapplicable en
soi et que les professionnels qui sont
sur le terrain s'ils peuvent entendre la
logique philosophique qui consiste à
mettre en parallèle les droits et les
devoirs savent que les 15h c'est une
réalité quasi inatteignable c'est cela
la réalité qu'il faut rappeler ici notre
groupe parlementaire pour être tout à
fait transparent avait une approche
relativement intéressé sur ce texte
certains considérant que la philosophie
des devoirs devait être entendue tous
nous avons dit que les droits étaient
défaillants tous nous l'avons relevé et
je veux dire ici que nous avons été
particulièrement attentif aux arguments
que vous avez développés pour essayer de
renforcer et d'améliorer
l'accompagnement mais que à l'heure où
nous nous parlons nous doutons encore de
la capacité que nous donnerons ensemble
à faire en sorte que la soit possible à
travers notamment les arbitrages
financiers le groupe lot fera donc en
sorte d'être cohérent sur les valeurs
que nous avons porté ceux qui parmi nous
étaient attentifs à la philosophie
initiale du texte s'abstiendront très
largement considérant que la méthode qui
a été choisie ne correspond pas à nos
attentes et pour la très grande majorité
du groupe nous voterons contre parce que
nous ne sommes pas en accord ni sur la
philosophie ni sur la méthode je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est au dernier
orateur madame Danielle Simonet pour la
France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise
merci merci de regagner vos places dans
le
calme madame la députée vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ne votez pas cette loi
ne votez pas cette loi malgré son titre
plein emploi elle ne créera aucun emploi
ne votez pas cette loi de maltraitance
et de régression sociale sans précédent
ne votez pas cette loi car elle incarne
un renversement de notre droit
constitutionnel alors chers collègues si
nos interventions de tous les groupes de
la nupes du groupe lot des députés
ultramarin ne vous ont pas convaincu
écoutez au moins la Défenseur des droits
elle qualifie cette réforme de
régression digne d'un retour du 19e
siècle un renversement majeur du devoir
constitutionnel et inconditionnel de
solidarité qui va appauvrir encore
davantage les plus pauvres pourquoi
faites-vous cette loi cette loi c'est la
suite de votre contreeréforme des
retraites imposé à coup de 493 contre la
vie de 93 % des actifs voler les deux
plus belles années de retraite au peuple
va créer 100000 àocatair au RSA
supplémentairire et des dizaines de
milliers de personnes en situation de
handicap et pour vous ça va coûter un
pognon de dingue même si c'est bien peu
comparé à tout ce que vous donnez en
cadeau aux assistés du 440 par cette loi
vous allez inscrire de forces à France
travail expo l'emploi les bénéficiaires
du RSA et leur conjointe et leur
conjoint les jeunes d'émissions local
les personnes en situation de handicap
et vous aviez même prévu comble de
l'absurd d'inscrire d'office les
personnes en invalidité la France mes
chers collègues compte que 300000
emplois non pourvus et 7,5 millions de
chômeurs vous échouez à préserver
l'emploi et vous cherchez à rendre
responsa les allocataires du RSA et les
chômeurs au boulot bande de feignantel
est votre message pourtant il travaille
déjà et dans un proche par vol il porte
gratuitement tant de solidarité malgré
les alertes des associations vous avez
décidé de vous allier à LR sous le
silence compli du rassemblement national
pour faire voter c'est au moins 15 he
d'activité obligatoire alors encore une
fois monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre nous vous demandons ce sera
combien d'heur au final vous avez
seulement dit qu'il y aurait ni plancher
ni plafond ce flou est inacceptable et
pour quelles activités nous avons appris
par monsieur le rapporteur qu'il
pourrait de stage d'immersion
professionnelle donc de travail gratuit
ou de travail sous-payé parce que tel
est votre autre objectif à travers cette
loi finalement faire pression à la
baisse sur les salaires dégrader les
conditions de travail et que tout le
monde soit contraint d'accepter
n'importe quel emploi n'importe quel
sous-emploi contrôler traquer humilier
les plus pauvres ne vous suffit pas vous
inventez la pédagogie par la fin en
menaçant de couper les allocations déjà
si faibles 500 €
et bien à des familles entières c'est ce
que vous appelez la suspension
remobilisation le constat il est là
chers collègues 400000 pauvres depuis
2017 depuis l'arrivée de Macron un
Français sur 3 saute un repas des
famille entière sont à la rue faute de
logement les restos du rang du cœur nous
appelle à l'aide et votre réponse
coupons leur le reste à vivre les
pauvres
sinserront à la fin ce sont les enfants
qui TR ayez au moins de l'humanité ne
votez pas cette loi aucune garantie non
plus pour les maires isolé alors que les
femmes représentent 96 % des
allocataires du RSA majoré tout sera
pris par décret auou circulaire au
Bonvouloir du roi notre service public
d'emploi est déjà fracassé par les
réformes successives au 5 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi vous allez en
ajouter 1,9 million de bénéficiaires du
RSA dans un immense fichier quel moyen
proposez-vous pour les agents
déjà suivre l'ensemble des personnes et
bien aucun même pas une formation pour
tous les agents aux situations de
handicap vous refuser une loi cadre qui
permettrait d'adapter les moyens aux
besoins votre solution
infin les opérateurs privés de plement
que l'ancien rapporteur connaît bien peu
importe que toutes les études concluent
qu'ils sont moins efficaces que le
service public la la solution pour vous
c'est l'externalisation c'est la
privatisation vous niz vous niz non le
malheur des uns pour vous fait le
business des autres c'est vraiment le
comble de votre cynisme enfin alors que
tous nos collègues ultramarin alerte sur
l'urgence sociale sur leur territoire et
la dégradation des services publics vous
niez leur rôle de représentant de la
nation par la volonté autoritaire de
passer par ordonnance une toute autre
logique est nécessaire préservons et
créons des emplois sur la planification
écologique et le développement des
services publics instaurons une garantie
défendons les territoires zé chur dont
vous coupez les budets et rappelez-vous
le préambule de la constitution de
46è nous allons nous allons à présent
procéder au scrutin je vous demande de
bien vouloir regagner vos
places le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
568 exprimé
561 majorité 281 pour 310 contre 251
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté la séance est suspendue pour 2
minutes